[Alkış]
Muhtemelen şu anda şaşırdınız Çünkü bu
söylediğim kelimelerin anlamını
bilmiyorsunuz
sizi
kıtaların selamlama cümlesiyle
karşılamak istedim Çünkü anlamı çok
güzel
ben seninim sende bensin Sana ne
yaparsam Kendime yapmışım
Aslında o kadar derin bir anlamı var ki
şunu demek istiyor ben seni seversem
Sana saygı duyarsam kendime saygı
göstermiş olurum sana bir kötülüğüm
dokunursa da kendime zararlı dokunmuş
olur aslında bizden 5000 yıl önce
yaşayan mayalar Sanki iyiliğin formülü
bulmuş gibi değil mi
şimdi iyilik iyiliğin dönüştürücü gücü
bence çok önemli bir tema Şifa ve iyilik
kavramları
önce size bir film izletmek istiyorum
[Müzik]
niye herkesin yavaş yavaş mutluluk
seviyesi artmaya başladı Çünkü bunun
bilimsel bir kanıtı var bir iyilik
yaptığımızda beyindeki 4 tane
kimyasalımız endorfin serotonin
oksitosin gibi 4 kimyasal artmaya
başlıyor salgılanmaya başlıyor Aslında
bu kimyasalların mutluluk halinin farklı
etkileri de var Örneğin tansiyonu
düşürüyor Kortizon hormonu olan stresi
azaltıyor yaraları bile
iyileştirebiliyor yani iyilik mutluluk
getirir mutluluk da iyilik yaptırır
Atatürk'ün en çok etkilendiği
filozoflardan birisi olan Cancan
iyi olalım sonra zaten mutlu oluruz
şimdi
insanlığın tarihinden itibaren en çok
sorulan sorulardan birisi doğuştan İyi
miyiz kötü müyüz Bu sorunun birçok
farklı cevabı var Önce küçük bir
bilimsel cevaptan başlayacağım yeni
Üniversitesinin bebek laboratuvarı var
Onların yaptığı bazı bebekler üzerinde
bazı deneyler çalışmışlar ve her insan
iyilik içgüleri ve aynı zamanda da
ötekileştirme ruhuyla birlikte doğuyor
Yani zamanla büyüdükçe
eğitimimiz ailemiz arkadaşlarımız
sosyokültürel çevremiz bizi bu
davranışlardan birine ya da daha fazla
eğilme vesile oluyor
bu arkadaki gördüğünüz
çok duygulan bir oldukça morarır
gördüğünüz gibi bu kızımız benim
ve yaklaşık orada 8 yaşında girmek
üzereyim birinci sınıftayım Kafamdaki
tacım ve hayatım
kızılan Kolu yok Kızılay kulun
başkanıyım Okulda da tacımı asla
çıkarmıyorum sınıfımız şu andaki olduğu
gibi değil 90 kişiyiz 90 tane arkadaşım
beni bulabilsin diye
o Kafamdaki tacı bir dakika olsun
çıkarmıyorum hayatındaki en önemli sahip
çıktım
kıyafetim diyeyim bir ürün Bir parça o
benim ve o yıllardan bu yıllara Aslında
kafamda şu anda görünmez bağlarla olan o
iyilik tacı eserinize diyebilirim şimdi
bahsettiğimiz gibi iyilik doğuştan
geliyor ama bir yandan da farklı bir
Ruha sahibiz Yani aslında aynı zevkten
olmayan aile duyguları taşımayan
insanlara da çok da hoş
karşılayamayabiliyoruz çok kapsayıcı
olamayabiliyoruz
şimdi
peki bireysel iyilik var bir de
toplumsal iyilik var çok duyuyorsunuzdur
sosyal değişim sosyal etki sosyal
dönüşüm nedir bu sosyal dönüşüm sosyal
evlilik sosyal girişimler şimdi bireysel
iyiliği kolektif bir şekilde
sistemleme dönüştüktürmek için sosyal
etki sosyal girişimlerde sosyal fayda
sağlayan yapılardır bir ticari
girişimler vardır bir sosyal girişimler
sosyal
girişimimizi toplumsal iyiliktir
bireylerdeki olan iyiliği
markalardaki olan iyiliği
topluma geri verilmesidir
şimdi
Sevgili kardeşim ama dünyaya geldikten
sonra kazandığım kardeşim ve ortağım
Oğuzhan canım 2012 yılında
Kırıkkale'de bir restoranın topladığı
bahşişleri fakirlere yemek olarak
vermesinden
askıda ekmek uygulamasını biliyor
Osmanlı'dan gelen ve Çocukluğunda
yaşadığı içgü
artı ona bir iyilik yapan ablanın
verdiği bir güç de iyiliğin dönüştürücü
gücüne inanarak ilk önce 2012 yılında
astronomi öldürüyor bu yıl Bu arada 10
yılımız
askıda ne var 2012'den itibaren önce
yemek iken sonrasında Diyoruz ki
İyilik her alanda olabilir ve Herkes
iyilik yapabilir iyilik birilerimizi
Özgür değildir içimizde Herkesin bir
iyilik yapma dürtüsü var bunu biliyoruz
Önemli olan bu kıvılcımı yakabilmek
askıda ne var ha önce yemekken daha
sonra ilk Ceylan Ertem hiç bana sormadan
bütün üniversite öğrencilerine benden 4
tane çift kişilik net bırakabilirsiniz
diyor derken diğer sanatçılarımız
yayınevlerimiz
mekanlar askıya davetiyeler kültür sanat
etkinlikleri kitaplar bırakmaya başlıyor
fark ettiniz mi bir iyilik hareketi
bireyden çıkıp nasıl topluluğa yayılıyor
daha sonra
markalarla birlikte
iyilik yapılan taraf kim burada diye
sorduğunuzda gençler Üniversite
öğrencileri iyilik yapılan taraf
ve toplumun diğer tüm üyeleri Sonuçta
biz markalarda görüşleri bir birey
olarak görüyoruz ve onların kararlarıyla
bize destekler veriliyor onları da ikna
ediyoruz Aslında buradaki
nasıl ortaya çıkıyor Çünkü
araştırmalara göre iyilik yapan da
iyilik yapılanla Hatta iyiliğe şahit
olan da mutlu oluyor yani sadece bir
başkasının mutlu etmek için değil
kendiniz için de iyilik yapıyoruz
baktığımızda Peki bu iyilik
hareketlerine nasıl görüyoruz Çevrenizde
işte bir arkadaşınız size bir mesaj
atıyor bir yerde bir öğrencinin ya da
bir ihtiyacı olan birinin desteğe
ihtiyacı var diyor bir bakıyorsunuz
kocaman bir aile olmuşsunuz Orada
aslında birbirini tanımayan İnsanların
birbirine destek verdiğini görüyorsunuz
Bu işe Tamamen
kendiliğinden olan bir iyilik yani
iyiliğin kendiliğinden geleni güzel
oluyor peki
[Müzik]
iyiliğin kadar öznel bir iyiliğin tanımı
var mıdır
vardır diyenlere el kaldırabilir mi
enteresan Evet iyiliğin Evrensel olarak
bir tanıma yapılmış
1990'lı yıllarda
sana yapılmasını istemediğim bir
davranışını başkalarına yapmamak deniyor
iyilik aslında ne kadar da mayalılarını
size verdiğim selamıyla aynı değil mi
iyilik bireylerden başlar topluma
yayılır asıl Toplumsal olarak iyi
olduğumuzda mutlu olduğumuza Neden şu
anda çevrenize bak En Yakın arkadaşınız
huzursuz olduğunda siz onu karşısına
geçip bilebiliyor musunuz iyi o iyiyim
diyebiliyor musunuz diyemezsiniz
karşılıklı Duygu alışverişi Bu benim
kimyalarının birbirine geçişidir şimdi
durumda
üniversite öğrencilerinin oldukça fazla
ihtiyacı olan alanlar vardı
toplu bir iyilik hareketi başlatmak
istiyorduk
nasıl başlatmışız bir görelim ve bunun
psikolojik ve felsefik etkilerini
konuşalım
[Müzik]
geriye dayalı içer
ik kullanmak ne olmuştur arkadaşlarıyla
Türkiye'deki gençlik araştırmaları
incelendi sonuçları Arasında 2 çarpıcı
gerçek üniversite dillerinin ekonomik
koşulları ile ilgili durumu ortaya
çıkartıyor Aslında devam Bu gerçeği
özeti yani
sosyal medyada güçlü bir ekonomik
yaratmak amacıyla üniversitede
belirlediği ne yaptığını söylemek
bakış açısından
reklamlar Yani
hastalara gençliğin arkasına alarak
bankaların onları
Evet
üniversitede öğrencilerine yemek kitap
kıyafet bile değil birçok ürün ve
iyilik istenir mi burada farkındaysanız
bir cümle kullanıyoruz iyilik yapması
için aksiyon almasını sağladı Evet
iyilik istenir Hatta sizi sevmeyen size
karşı nötr olan birinden İy
istediğinizde o kişinin sizi sevme ve
bir daha iyilik yapma ihtimali artıyor
Hatta buna
Benjamin Franklin etkisi deniyor
Amerika'nın kurucusu elektriğin artı
eksi kutuplarda bulan mucit ünlü filozof
ve yazar
dini
[Müzik]
düşün Birsel uyumsuzluk teorisi bu çünkü
bir insan karşıdaki bir iyilik yapıyorsa
onu sevmesi gerekiyordu ya hissediyor
değil Ve bu hayatta uygulama uygulanan
bir
teori Çünkü baktığınızda şöyle çıkmış
Aslında çok Kısaca anlatayım Benjamin
franklinin çok Böyle düşman olan bir
milletvekili varmış demiş ki ben bunu
nasıl kazanabilirim çok akıllı bir adam
bu bunu kazanmak istiyorum
kütüphanesinde çok nadir bulunan bir
kitap var mektup yazmış demiş ki bu
kütüphanedeki kitabı rica edebilir miyim
almış kitabı okumuş sonrasında Bu
kitabın ona hayatını etkilerinden
bahsetmiş ve Çok teşekkür etmiş daha
sonra çok uzun yıllar başlayan
dostlukları başlamış Yani özetle
Bu nedenle iyiliği istemek de önemli
iyiliği yapmak da önemli ikisinin
dengesi daha da önemli şimdi
iyiliğin dönüştürücü etkisinden
bahsedeceğiz dedik İyilik nasıl
dönüştürüyor insan nasıl iyileştiriyor
İyilik nasıl Şifa Aslında sizlere
bizlere iyilik
kavram
ı sadece
fayda odaklı bir kavram değil arkadaşlar
iyiliğin tanımına sözlükte baktığınızda
şu yazar
karşılık beklemeden yapılan yardım Hayır
böyle bir şey yok sosyal girişimler
zaten
iyilik kavramını herkes faydalanıyorsa
karşılık beklemeden diye bir şey yok
Çünkü psikolojik olarak da bir karşılığı
var maddi olarak da bir karşılığı
olabilir yani siz bir hayvanın kafasını
sevdiğinizde de bir iyilik yapıyorsunuz
bir yaşlı teyzeyi karşıdan karşıya
geçirmeye destek olduğunuzda da iyilik
yapıyorsunuz yani karşılık
beklemiyorsunuz değil Onun size bir
sarılması bir Gülümse sizin Aslında
belki o Gününüzün tamamına iyi geçmesini
sağlıyor şimdi askıda ne kadar
hikayelerine baktığımızda Tabii ki
onuncu yılımıza girdiğimiz için büyük
bir dönüşüm hikayesi seyrediyoruz Çünkü
fayda alan taraf nasıl fayda veren
tarafa dönüşüyor iyilik yapılan taraf
nasıl iyilik yapan tarafa dönüşüyor o
kadar güzel örnekler var ki Daha önce
Aslında ne var Ben bir ürün ve hizmet
kazanan bir öğrenci bir şirkete giriyor
okuduktan sonra Sonuçta bir iş yeri
sahibi oluyor belki bir girişimci oluyor
ama aldığı o desteği hiç olmadığı bir
anda evine gelen bir bilgisayar ya da
çok morali bozuk olduğu bir günde
Kültür Sanat etkinliğine gittiğini asla
unutamıyor diyor ki ben de hiç
tanımadığım başkalarına yardım
yapabilirim diyor gidiyor markalardaki
yönlerini ikna ediyor O kadar çok
hikayeler var ki bunun şimdi bir tane
Efe'nin hikayesini dinleyeceğiz Efe
Teknosa'da çalışıyordu Ve askıda ne
vardı yararlanan bir öğrenciydi şöyle
Efe'nin çok içten değil
di O zaman belki bana bir fikir
bir gün okulda kara köpek ve vapuru
neden artemi gördüm Yanında oturuyordu
somethetmek istedim böyle bir sohbete
geçtim kendisiyle söyledim hatta Yani
ben işte pozisyonda geldi mekanda en
önde Sürgün dedim hastanelerden kazandım
Teşekkür ederim ettiği için bize Kendisi
de zaten astronomi destekçisi o gün
konsere gittiğimde attım aklımdan
geçirmiştim dedim ki bir gün ben de
çalıştığım bir durumda
ne İş yaparsam yapayım bir şekilde
destek vermek istiyorum Hem başka birisi
Ee bir şekilde öğrencilere dokunabilmek
istiyorum bu konuları diye ve sonrasında
O gün dediğim şeyi yapıyorum
Evet
fayda alan taraf fayda verene dönüştü
Peki bu dönüşüm herkese vuruyor mu o
iyilik Herkesin içinde yanıyor mu evet
yanıyor sadece fırsat Yani siz
fırsatları iyi değerlendirdiğinizde size
her zaman aslında iyilik yapma fırsatı
doğuyor Yeter ki bunun sadece maddi veya
büyük olduğunu sürekli beyninize
düşürmek zorunda kaldım pandemi dönemi
biliyorsunuz
hepimiz için çok zordu özellikle
üniversite öğrencileri Çok zorlan neden
bir defa aileleri işlerini kaybettiler
destek olamıyorlar herkes evden evinde
herkesin bilgisayar var ya Yani siz şu
anda Türkiye'de
her öğrencinin evinde internet veya
bilgisayar var diye bir durum yok
Sonuçta biz de dedik ki; bir iyilik
hareketi başlatalım askıda eğitim var
yapabilir Bu sefer ve binlerce
üniversite öğrencisine yüzlerce laptop
binlerce internet paketi kitap seti
yiyor Demek ki bir sürü farklı şeyleri
artık ve birçok marka ile birlikte Makro
soft Borusan bir sürü farklı farklı
dilimizde
ne
yaptık biz her zaman şunu
istiyoruz sen de ufak tefek demeden
Birine bir iyilik yapabilirsin
peki
Biz de biz size destek olalım evinize
veya
arkadaşınıza bunu gördünüz şahit oldunuz
siz de bizden kazandıklarınızla
bir üniversite destek olmak ister
misiniz dedik
Tevfik Vakfı'na bağışlamalarını istedik
ve
binlerce üniversite öğrencisi 5-10 lira
demeden bağışladı özellikle
herkesin Kafasında bir iyilik tacı var
görünmezliklerle bağlı kafamıza
bunun dönüşüm etkisini hissedeceksiniz
Yeter ki içinizdeki o kıvılcımı o
kucaklamayı kapsayıcılı barındırın
teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]